I don't know what to tell you man okay
fat pride that's what I wanted to go on
to stupid fat pride my god ders look at
this there's nothing to be proud about
I'm disgusting how could I be proud
about being fat oh yeah I'm proud
because I ate the half of this frickin
pizza I mean it's good it's a good pizza
but there's nothing to be proud about
Cheers
uh by the way I protect you on YouTube
when anyone makes comments you know how
would you see that no yeah I'm always
like I he's great but listen it's no
secret that you're not you're no you're
no you're no bantamweight what the hell
does that even mean
it's below what he does trying to
contrast it but we wrote about this at
louder with Crowder that fat models know
that was gross they're mad that there
aren't enough black fat male model of
fat models now that's the issue have you
seen that an affirmative action for bat
models and I was honestly fund up I find
this interesting because you're a bigger
guy and you don't like it when anyone
else makes you know fat jokes you can
make it but you you hate fat pride
oh it's obnoxious what I can't I don't
I'm not proud of my skin I'm not proud
of all the crud that's underneath it
pride is something that you're supposed
to take in something you've accomplished
I learned how to play that song all the
way through on a bass I can take pride
in that
I edited some piece of audio in the
software in my office and I did a good
job I take pride in that I took a cool
photograph I painted a picture I I
sculpted a sculpture that's something
you don't take pride in the crap you
were born into or the fact that you ate
16 pizzas and two pots of coffee on a
Thursday evening we didn't eat them you
drank them but there's nothing to take
pride in in
stuff that's just happening I mean if
you were trying to get up to 400 pounds
and you were really making an effort at
it and you were say under weight then
yeah oh I I can take pride in the fact
that I put on two hundred and fifty
pounds because you're trying to do it
maybe that was some live art crap that
you were doing but for crying out loud
don't take pride in it it's it's just
sort of there I didn't expect you to go
off that much but but you could then say
the same thing about gay pride if you're
just born gay yeah I don't understand
that either white pride black pride gay
pride it's there's not it's not
something you built you didn't build
that it just happened
III don't think with you it just
happened it's a practice yeah I mean the
pizza didn't come on its own somebody
had to order it unless you make it
selling it's one of those video games
where it's just like was it Burger Time
yeah yeah all right other yeah I can't
be proud of being fat I just am well
there you have it straight from the
horse's like proud of being Canadian for
God's sake uh-uh fat fried not really a
thing water with Browder stay tuned if
you like this video subscribe by
clicking my face and if you hated it
well join the club and you're gonna hate
this next video right next to me but
doesn't a part of you want to know what
it is